Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Ah!
Es lag an der Telekom.
Geil, oder?
Wie der...
Was macht die Telekom, bitteschön?
Oh, ich übersteuere.
Ähm, was macht die Telekom eigentlich?
Was soll denn das Scheiß?
Jetzt ist alles gut, jetzt funktioniert's wunderbar.
Soll ich mich einen Ticken leiser machen, oder ist gut so?
Ja, ja, wunderbar, gut.
Dann, dann können wir jetzt ja anfangen.
Dann können wir jetzt ja anfangen, perfekt.
So, dann mach ich mir nochmal ein neues Tab auf,
dass der Kram auch ordentlich lädt.
So, jetzt muss ich mir das nochmal selbst in der Vorschau angucken.
Wie sieht das hier aus jetzt?
Hast du noch Kontakt mit dem Kaboom?
Äh, ja, ab und zu, ja.
Das ist ja, das ist ja schon antik, die Copypasta.
Das ist ja, das ist überhaupt nicht mehr im Trend.
Okay, jetzt scheint alles zu funktionieren.
Super.
So, na wenigstens, Epis.
Perfekt.
So, können wir jetzt ja anfangen.
Hallo T-Zap.
Dann können wir jetzt ja anfangen, ich zeige euch mal was.
Hab ich ja gerade gesagt.
Ich stream jetzt zum ersten Mal vom neuen Rechner.
Und mit ein bisschen Anlaufschwierigkeit hat es jetzt ja auch funktioniert.
Ich pass mal auf, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Ich hoffe das geht überhaupt von hier.
Pass mal auf.
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt meinen Rechner stable übertaktet.
Ähm, das sieht man jetzt nicht.
Ich müsste mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen Last verursachen.
Ich hab meinen Rechner jetzt stable übertaktet.
Auf 5 Gigahertz.
Ich muss mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Prime 95, irgendwann ein altes Prime oder so runterladen.
Wobei, ihr könnt's mir einfach glauben.
Ich hab meinen Rechner jetzt übertaktet auf stable 5 Gigahertz.
Er läuft mit 5,1.
Mein, mein, mein 8700K.
Allerdings muss man übertrieben viel Spannung draufhauen, dass er das macht.
Äh, Pavillonman fragt ob damit jetzt, ach so ist die Chat Einblendung, ja die Chat Einblendung funktioniert.
Gut.
Ähm, ob damit jetzt das neue Cod ordentlich läuft.
Naja, das kackt immer noch ab und zu ab wenn man raus tappt.
Das ist halt, das ist halt Cod.
Aber es läuft besser als auf dem alten Rechner.
Also es läuft schneller als auf dem alten Rechner.
Also stabiler läuft's auch nicht als auf dem alten Rechner.
Naja, zumindest stable.
Ist er jetzt auf 6 Kern mit 5 Gigahertz.
Und ich hab da stundenlang Prime laufen lassen, real bench und haste nicht gesehen den ganzen Scheiß.
Und das funktioniert.
Das ist natürlich super.
Ich hab jetzt halt eingestellt, dass er sich runter taktet, das wäre ja auch total beknackt.
Wenn, wenn er sich, warum sollte ich mir Strom verschwenden als sein muss.
Ja, ist nice.
Und das, ihr könnt euch ja vielleicht noch an den Übertaktungstream erinnern.
Also ich hab die CPU jetzt.
Ihr könnt euch ja vielleicht noch an den Übertaktungstream erinnern, den ich, kann ich sagen, dass ich das nie machen will.
I will never translate German will ich haben.
Außer will ich meinen, außer will ich meinen Browser auf Englisch haben.
Settings, Language, geht das hier?
Ey, es ist doch schon auf Englisch.
Warum ist, warum ist Google denn jetzt auf Deutsch?
Achso, weil es Google.de ist.
Aber Google, selbst Google.de ist halt, ah Change to Englisch, geht doch, ja.
Ja, wunderbar.
Ich hab ja riesen Glück gehabt, ne.
Und hab noch ein 8700k bekommen.
Ich hab vorbestellt bei drei verschiedenen Shops.
Direkt zur Release.
Quasi noch vor Release hab ich den bestellt.
Und bei drei Shops.
Bei Conrad.
Bei Mindfactory.
Und bei so einem Berliner IT-Laden.
Keine Ahnung, stand halt bei Geizhals.
Stand da halt drinne.
Zeig euch das mal.
Weil mich jetzt einige Leute schon gefragt haben, wie ich denn 8700k gekriegt hab.
Ähm.
Das könnten die gewesen sein.
Der war aber nicht so teuer meiner.
Wobei so 40 Euro Aufpreis, wenn man jetzt unbedingt haben will, ist auch okay.
Ähm.
Ach, mittlerweile sind 8700k lieferbar.
Ne, doch nicht. Lagern.
Waren wir mal lagern.
Ahja.
Boah, die hauen aber rein hier vom Preis her.
Also ich hab bei Mindfactory Conrad, und ich glaube die hier waren das.
Wo ich auch bestellt hab.
Jaja, in Berlin. Genau.
So.
Und die haben wohl irgendwie.
Scheint wohl ein bisschen kleinerer Laden zu sein.
Und die haben wohl welche bekommen.
Und ich war wohl einer der wenigen oder einer der ersten, die dort was bestellt haben.
Und dann hab ich quasi zwei Wochen oder eineinhalb Wochen nach Release.
Quasi den 8700k gekriegt.
Der jetzt da quasi schon nicht zu bekommen ist.
So.
Also ich sehs aber auch nicht ein.
Manche Shops hier, ne.
Die irgendwie, man die CPU soll mal 399 kosten.
Und manche Shops hier unten so 500, 600.
Ja ist klar, ne.
Also so viel wert wärs mir dann doch nicht gewesen.
Äh sag mal so 39 Euro Aufpreis, wenn man jetzt unbedingt einen haben will.
Würde ich sagen, das kann man machen.
Ja.
Am besten ist natürlich, man kriegt die CPU für das wie es gedacht ist.
Ich hatte halt übrigens Glück.
Wie gesagt, ich hab irgendwie keinen Kontakt mit Intel gehabt.
Oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Ja.
Einfach Glück gehabt.
So und der läuft jetzt stable.
Weil irgendjemand gesagt hat auf 5 Gigahertz, 5 Gigahertz braucht man nicht.
Der läuft jetzt stable auf 5 Gigahertz.
Und Cache glaube ich auf 4,4.
Nachdem ich ein bisschen im BIOS rumgebastelt hab.
Also sprich ein bisschen Spannung umgestellt hab.
Ein bisschen wie heißt das, wie heißt das bei Intel jetzt?
Line Level Calibration und Zeug.
Halt rumprobiert.
Und ich hab jetzt die Lüfter auch so eingestellt.
Auf Silence.
Also sprich ich höre jetzt vom Rechner nichts.
Außer er macht halt was.
So.
Gut, das wollte ich jetzt mal los werden an der Stelle.
Ja und weil jemand geschrieben hat 5 Gigahertz braucht man nicht.
Ich mein, warum braucht man die nicht?
Das ist jetzt die Frage.
Ich mein, warum nicht?
Ich mein, die CPU hat man.
Man hat für die CPU schon Geld ausgegeben.
Man hat auch den Geld für das Lüfter ausgegeben.
Also für den ordentlichen Lüfter ausgegeben.
Für das Mainboard ausgegeben.
Warum soll man das nicht übertakken?
Nur weil man vielleicht anstatt...
Keine Ahnung, die 10 oder 15 Prozent, 10, 20 Prozent FPS am Ende nicht mehr braucht.
Weil man eh schon so viel hat.
Ja.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man sagen, man kann nie genug FPS haben.
Mal angenommen, man schafft es mit Übertakten von Grafikkarte und CPU nochmal so 20 Prozent oder so an Leistung rauszuholen.
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen 120 und 144 FPS.
Und das ist doch nicht schlecht.
Zumal es kostet ja auch nicht mehr.
So, Grafikkarte übertakten muss ich auch noch machen.
Ich muss mal ausprobieren, wie viel meine 1008 STI letztendlich packt.
Habe ich noch nie getestet.
Aber ich denke mal, das was ich hier so am Start habe, dürfte jetzt so mit das schnellste System sein.
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig auch ziemlich gut.
Was man zur Zeit für Gaming so kriegen kann.
Ohne jetzt in die ganz extremen zu gehen.
Also in die ganz extremen meine ich jetzt irgendwie irgendwelche Titan X-Ti.
Oder wie heißt das Ding, Titan XP oder so.
Oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Preis-Leistung finde ich mein System echt nice.
So, aber jetzt kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen Thema heute.
Jetzt habe ich hier lange über meinen Rechner gelabert, was wir machen wollen.
Zwar, ich habe gesehen, dass ZFS on Linux den Encryption-Poll-Request gemurtscht hat.
Wenn ich das jetzt mal finden würde.
Dann haben die schon vor einer Weile gemurtscht.
Also sprich, die ZFS-Implementierung für Linux hat jetzt Verschlüsselung eingebaut.
Und das wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Das einzige Problem bei der Sache ist, es gibt noch keinen offiziellen Release.
Ich finde den Branch nicht.
Wo ist es denn?
Es gibt noch keinen offiziellen Branch dafür.
Beziehungsweise noch keinen offiziellen Release dafür.
Wo ZFS mit quasi eingebauter Verschlüsselung release ist.
Wo ist das denn? Ich finde den Branch jetzt gar nicht.
Bin ich jetzt total bescheuert?
Das ist er nicht.
Das Schöne ist, hier sieht man es.
Das Geile ist, dass man damit jetzt zum ersten Mal die Möglichkeit hat.
Und das werden wir heute mal ausprobieren, ob wir das überhaupt gebacken kriegen.
Zum ersten Mal die Möglichkeit hat, alles mit ZFS zu machen.
Also sprich, du hast ZFS noch nicht verpasst, wir haben noch gar nicht angefangen.
Man hat zum ersten Mal die Möglichkeit, quasi alles mit ZFS zu machen.
Bisher war das unter Linux so.
Ich hole jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter aus.
In der Zwischenzeit laden wir uns schon mal ein Ubuntu ISO runter.
Wir brauchen übrigens das Desktop ISO, obwohl wir kein Desktop-System installieren werden.
Das sagt zumindest die offizielle Anleitung.
Ja, lad mal runter.
In der Zeit, wo das runterlädt, kann ich schon noch was erzählen.
Also ich muss jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter ausholen.
ZFS ist ein, ganz grob gesagt, ein Dateisystem.
Also, wenn ich jetzt sage, sowas wie NTFS unter Windows, wird das der Sache nicht so wirklich gerecht.
Aber ein Dateisystem erst mal wie NTFS.
Bloß, dass es halt noch viel mehr drum herum kann.
Das ist auch kein reines Dateisystem.
Das hat quasi RAID-Funktionalität mit eingebaut.
Das hat Integritätschecks eingebaut.
Also sprich, dass das auf der Platte auch wirklich noch stimmt, was da steht.
Das kann sich selbst reparieren.
Das hat, habe ich schon gesagt, dass es RAID-Funktion eingebaut hat, keine Ahnung.
Es kann Snapshots erstellen.
Man kann beispielsweise von seinem Rechner an einen anderen Rechner, wo ZFS drauf ist, das steht hier auch ganz,
kann man quasi komplette Snapshots und, ich nenne es mal Partitionen, sind keine Partitionen, nennt sich Dataset.
Bei ZFS kann man komplett zu einem anderen Rechner rüber schicken.
Das macht natürlich Backups auch ziemlich einfach.
Und ZFS ist an sich schon eine richtig geile Geschichte.
Es kommt ursprünglich von Sun, von Sun für Solaris.
Ist das mal ursprünglich entwickelt worden.
Und der Code kommt soweit, ich weiß, noch aus Zeiten, wo Sun mal gesagt hat, wir machen jetzt Teile von Solaris,
also Open Solaris, machen wir Open Source.
Und mittlerweile wurde Sun ja von Oracle aufgekauft.
Und Oracle hat jetzt gesagt, wir machen das Ganze wieder dicht.
Der Code, den Sun allerdings mal veröffentlicht hat, ist immer noch unter Open Source Lizenz verfügbar.
Das hat sich das Open ZFS Projekt genommen.
Die hier haben sich das genommen.
Und es gibt jetzt ZFS Implementierungen für BSD und für Linux und für diesen Open Solaris Nachfolger und solche Sachen.
Und mittlerweile hat das zur Closed Source Lösung nicht nur aufgeschlossen, sondern sie teilweise sogar schon überholt.
Und der letzte Schritt für mich war jetzt eigentlich, dass sie jetzt auch quasi Verschlüsselungssystem eingebaut haben in ZFS.
Das bedeutet, also was das Ganze richtig cool macht, ist, früher hat man unter Linux quasi drei verschiedene Teile gebraucht,
um ein Raid zu betreiben, ein verschlüsseltes Raid zu betreiben, das man auch ordentlich unterteilen kann an die Festplatten.
Dann hat man quasi für das Raid, hat man MD-Raid verwendet,
für die Festplattenverschlüsselung hat man sowas wie LUX verwendet
und für diese Positionierung und Volume Management hat man LVM verwendet.
Und das kann man jetzt alles mit ZFS, alles in einem machen, plus die Vorteile, die man eben mit ZFS hat.
Das Problem ist, wie ich schon gesagt habe, es gibt noch keine Version, die eben diese Verschlüsselungsfunktion anhält,
deswegen kompilieren wir das selbst. Und dann, und das ist der große Knackpunkt,
und dann versuchen wir, also ich glaube, ZFS selbst zu kompilieren und die Module zu laden, ist nicht so schwierig.
Wir haben ja auch eine ganz gute Anleitung hier dafür.
Wir suchen jetzt mal die andere Anleitung für Ubuntu ran, die Custom Packages müssen wir uns erst mal raussuchen.
Das ist nicht so schwer, aber der richtige Knackpunkt wird dann, wir versuchen das System von diesem ZFS dann zu booten.
So, und ich, ob das funktioniert, da habe ich so meine Zweifel, ehrlich gesagt.
So, jetzt legen wir, also es kann durchaus sein, dass das in die Hose geht, weil es ist ein Unterschied,
ob man quasi ein System bootet und dort dann irgendwie ein Laufwerk einhängt und so eine ZFS-Funktion verwendet,
oder ob man quasi direkt davon bootet, also sprich, man hat kein laufendes System, wo man das dann lädt,
sondern man versucht davon zu booten. Das bedeutet, es muss alles glatt gehen, sprich, der Crap darf keinen Strich durch die Rechnung machen.
Beim Booten braucht man alle Module und Zeugs. Also, ich weiß, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Also, es gibt hier eine schöne Anleitung für Ubuntu, wie man den Ubuntu von ZFS bootet.
Das gibt es, die funktioniert auch, das habe ich schon ausprobiert, mein Server hier daheim läuft auch auf dem ZFS-Route,
allerdings ohne Verschlüsselung und das von Ubuntu mitgeliefert ZFS, aber wir kompilieren das jetzt ja selbst.
Ja doch, Tracks Freak, natürlich will ich das verschlüsseln. Oder was meinst du mit keine Passphrase? Also, ich will ein Passwort eintippen, dass er soll Passwort prompt,
oder naja, es muss kein Passwort prompt sein, es ist auch okay, wenn er mich irgendwie auf eine Shell schmeißt,
und ich dann quasi manuell das anlocken muss und dann continue, also ihn weiterbooten lasse, das ist auch okay. Aber das soll nicht booten, ohne dass ich Passwort eingegeben habe.
Ja, ja, ja, Mr. Army, ich verwende den neuen PC. So, ähm, this PC, nein, Downloads, Ubuntu, zack.
Ich will, nein, nein, wir sagen lieber, dass wir das later installen, sonst das macht vor allem noch komische Dinger.
Linux, wir haben einen Ubuntu 64, ähm, wisst ihr was, wir stellen mal drei CPUs ein, ich meine, ich habe jetzt einen neuen Rechner, wunderbar.
Tracksfreak sagt, mein Problem war, dass du beim Booten nicht die Passphrase angeben kannst.
Das Booten dafür nicht erbrochen werden kann, bei mir hat das irgendwo versteckt, nur mit Schlüssel versteckt funktioniert.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Also, ich glaube auch nicht, dass das schon eingebaut ist.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass dort Init, RamFS, Scripts und Sachen schon mit dabei sind,
die das quasi von Haus aus ermöglichen direkt zu Booten von ZFS und dich nach einer Passphrase fragen.
Das wird nicht funktionieren, aber das Booten wird ja irgendwie früher oder später abkacken.
Und wenn das Booten abkackt, schmeißt es mich auf eine Shell und wenn ich von der Shell ZFS anlocke und dann weiterboote, das sollte eigentlich funktionieren.
Wichtig ist nur, dass wir Boot auf eine eigene Partition legen und nicht mit verschlüsseln, weil Krabb kann keine ZFS Encryption.
Soweit ich weiß.
So, legen wir mal die VM an, kommen wir hier 4.690, nein, 4.696.
Ich meine, wir haben ja genug, ne?
Nö, warum sieht der Taskmanager so kacke aus?
Mein, wir haben ja genug. Ist ja nicht so, dass wir hier zu wenig Leistung hätten.
Ich hab, muss ich mal überlegen, wie hängen geblieben das ist.
Ich hab drei Netzwerkkarten auf dem Mainboard.
Ich brauch keine drei Netzwerkkarten, aber als SROC war da Meinung, nein, wir müssen da jetzt drei Netzwerkkarten draufbauen.
Gut, das hier ist vor allem da.
Ich meine, ich hab ja genug, 16 GB RAM, genug CPU Kerne, kann ich also ordentlich draufbauen hier.
Bridge Network, bla, bla, bla, ist eigentlich Musik und mein Gelaber von der Lautstärkeabmischung so, okay, ja, denke schon.
Ich hab ja so ein bisschen Chill-Enspannungsmusik im Hintergrund laufen.
So, create new disk, store in single file, ach, keine Ahnung, 40 GB.
Boah, wir könnten es jetzt noch mal ne Runde krasser machen.
Wir könnten den ZFS Rate 1 machen.
Nee, nee, wir lassen es einfach mit einer Disk, von der wir booten.
Wir müssen es ja nicht komplizierter machen, als es ist.
Ach ja, und übrigens, eine Sache würde ich auch noch gerne mal ausprobieren, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich gebe zu, das ist ein bisschen advancede Geschichte, aber ich wollte es schon lange mal ausprobieren.
Also das Ganze, was wir heute machen, ist ein bisschen advanceder.
Und ihr könnt mich auch gerne alles Mögliche zu fragen, auch so nach dem Motto WTF, was machst du da eigentlich?
Ich will eine Sache noch mal ausprobieren, das wollte ich schon lange mal ausprobieren.
Und zwar, ich möchte meinen Rechner, also quasi die verschlüsselte Partition und die verschlüsselte Festplatte,
wo ich beim Booten dann mein Passport eingeben muss, das will ich nicht lokal machen vom Rechner, sondern über SSH.
Das heißt, wir müssen in unser Bootsystem auch noch einen SSH-Server reinhauen.
Da weiß ich aber grob, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, geiles Result hier. WTF, was machst du da eigentlich?
Ich versuche, ein Linux zu installieren, das von einem verschlüsselten ZFS-Laufwerk bootet.
So, weiter, weiter, Hardware, schmeißen wir den Drucker, brauchen wir nicht, Soundkarte brauchen wir auch nicht,
USB kann man dranlassen, Laufwerk hängen wir jetzt Ubuntu ISO ein, Finish, da ist die VM.
So, wir stellen die VM jetzt noch mal um, dass sie nicht BIOS bootet, sondern UEFI bootet.
Gibt es nicht Alternativen zu CRUB, die davon booten können?
Ja, es gibt ein paar andere Bootmanager, aber CRUB finde ich ist der beste.
Und ich glaube, wenn das CRUB nicht kann, kann das keiner.
Also CRUB kann von ZFS booten, CRUB kann allerdings soweit, ich weiß nicht, von verschlüsseltem ZFS booten,
weil es einfach nicht implementiert ist.
Was auch immer das ist, ich möchte das nicht attachen.
So, und ich habe auch Insta, es ist gefinished und alles.
So, ähm, ups.
Was ist das wieder für Musik, ey?
Ich hasse so Chillmusik, wo da im Ende noch rumgelabert wird.
Ah, wird schon gleich vorbei sein.
Wir tryen jetzt mal Ubuntu und ich mach mal Fullscreen.
Und dann gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Ähm, kann man das nicht ausblenden hier oben? Geh weg.
Piss dich alle. Und das Release soll auch weg.
Vmware, mach dich vom Acker, ich will das nicht sehen da oben.
Ah, jetzt ist weg, sehr schön.
Oh.
Okay, hat funktioniert.
So, als erstes installieren wir jetzt mal Vmware-Tools, dass wir das in Vollbild kriegen.
Und dann haben wir uns die Anleitung hier drauf auf, wie das funktioniert.
Ups, äh, äh.
Englische Tastatur, das müssen wir auch noch gleich umstellen.
Abinstall, Open, Vm, ne, Open, V.
Open, Vm, Tools.
So, nein. Jetzt, aber.
Genau.
Max, was hältst du von Camelot Unchained?
Ähm, ich hab das gebacked.
Vmware, wo ist das? User?
Ne, so heißt es glaub ich bei Ubuntu.
Wunderbar.
So, jetzt haben wir den ganzen Camel nämlich auf Fullscreen.
Jetzt stellen wir erst mal die Tastatur um.
Äh, was halt ich von Camelot Unchained?
Moment, äh, äh, Language.
Jetzt mal Deutsch einstellen.
Ich hab's gebacked, aber, ähm, also erstens sind sie hinter, des Todes hinter dem Zeitplan, ja.
Mehr hinter dem Zeitplan kannst du eigentlich nicht sein, wie die.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das mit der aktuellen Beta überhaupt aussieht.
Ob das da jetzt, ist die, weißt du das?
Ähm, wer hat das gerade gefragt?
Äh, Tu, Yu, Ma, Ma, Ma, Ma, Ji.
Weißt du, wie das mit der aktuellen Beta von Camelot Unchained aussieht?
Das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt hab, die hätte ja schon 2016 oder irgendwie so rauskommen sollen.
Ähm, äh ja.
Fail halt, ne.
Was mir überhaupt nicht gefällt ist, dieses
Crafting-System, was sie eingebaut haben.
Das nervt mich einfach nur.
Ich mach mal die Schrift ein bisschen größer, dass man hier was sieht.
Das Crafting-System von Camelot Unchained geht mir einfach nur auf den Sack.
Also, dass man sowas einbaut.
Also nicht das Crafting-System, sondern dieses, dieses, äh, fake, fake, äh, Minecraft, ähm.
Wo stellt man, wo stellt man hier?
Ah, hier unten.
Oh, dass man ordentlich was sieht.
Was haben wir hier sonst, was haben wir hier zu bieten?
Ach, das passt schon.
Ich mag die Ubuntu, die Standard-Ubuntu-Terminal-Schrift nicht.
Also, das ist Live-CD, was wir hier gebootst haben jetzt.
Und jetzt machen wir mal die Anleitung auf
auf GitHub vom ZFS-Projekt.
Wo drinne steht, wie man sich eigene ZFS-Pakete baut.
Denn das Ziel ist ja, wir wollen ein
native-encrypted ZFS-System verwenden.
Und davon gibt's noch kein offizielles Release.
Bei Ubuntu ist, ähm,
wie heißt das, heißt ZFS Linux das Paket?
Ne, wie heißt denn das?
Ja, also bei Ubuntu ist ZFS 0.6.5 dabei.
Aktuell, offiziell, letztes Release ist glaube ich 0.7.3.
Und Encryption soll erst mit 0.8 reinkommen.
Verstehe ich auch, die wollen, dass das System
erst mal getestet ist und stabil ist.
Bevor sie da offiziell was raushauen, releasen.
Aber wir wollen jetzt schon was probieren.
Ja.
Gut, ähm, ganz wichtig, ohne mach ich nix.
Und erinnert mich dran, falls ich vergesse,
ich muss Snapshots, Snapshots machen.
Also immer, immer wenn ich was hingekriegt hab,
was ganz gut funktioniert, muss ich einen Snapshot machen.
Sonst wäre das echt blöd.
Die Live-CD, die speichert ja nix.
Ok, ähm, Custom Packages.
Wir wollen Custom Packages haben für Ubuntu.
Das heißt wir müssen jetzt erst mal,
wir müssen jetzt erst mal irgendwelche
Build Tools installieren, das kriegen wir gebacken.
RPM Only bringt uns nix, RPM und Debian ist ok.
Oh, es gibt kein DKMS für Ubuntu, das ist doof.
Das ist blöd.
So, habt ihr ne Ahnung, was der Unterschied ist
zwischen dem und dem?
Also rein rhetorisch gefragt, dass ihr jetzt sagen könnt,
nein, dass ich das erklären kann.
Also sprich, wenn man zudestliche Kernel-Module
einbauen möchte, gibt es da verschiedene Varianten von.
Und ich finde, das hier ist eigentlich die angenehmste Variante,
weil normalerweise muss das Kernel-Modul exakt
zum aktuell benutzten Kernel passen.
In dem Fall ist es hier eine Nilungs-Kernel 4.13.0.16.
Blah, Dings, Ubuntu.
Und wenn ich jetzt ein Kernel-Modul baue,
muss es exakt zu dieser Kernel-Version passen.
Und sobald ich den Kernel update, müsste ich quasi
die Kernel-Module neu kompilieren.
Und wenn ich das mit DKMS mache, das enthält quasi
alle Build-Skripte und sonstige Sachen,
dann macht ihr das beim Kernel-Update automatisch.
Oder kann er beim Kernel-Update automatisch machen.
Kannst du dafür nur von Dora empfehlen?
Ja, ja, könnte man, könnte man.
Aber wir machen das jetzt mit Ubuntu.
Okay, also, das erste, was wir machen müssen,
wir müssen irgendwelche Voraussetzungen installieren,
dass wir überhaupt kompilieren dürfen.
Das machen wir mal.
Was?
Ach so, Moment.
Ich hab eins vergessen.
Ich muss erst mal updaten.
Und wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Pakete,
paar Paketquellen.
Und paar Paketrepos aktivieren,
dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Danach geht es wahrscheinlich.
Enabled, Update.
Ja, jetzt lädt er sich auch mal die neuesten Paketquellen runter.
Das heißt, jetzt gibt es auch ein bisschen mehr zur Auswahl.
Und jetzt funktioniert es.
So, das sind die Voraussetzungen, die man braucht,
laut dieser Anleitung,
dass man überhaupt ZFS kompilieren darf.
Oder kann.
So, den anderen Krempel installieren wir auch noch.
Hallo, Browser.
So, ganzen Krempel installieren.
Wohlgemerkt, das hier ist nur ein Live-System.
Also alles, was ich hier drauf installiere,
ist nach dem Reboot weg.
Deswegen muss ich unbedingt Snapshots zwischendurch machen.
So, ich mach mal die Schrift ein bisschen größer.
Ich hoffe, man erkennt das hier ganz gut.
Ich komm mal kurz in die Vorschau, ob das so weit passt.
Ja, ich glaube, man erkennt alles ganz gut, oder?
Erkennt man alles gut?
Also in meiner Vorschau sieht es okay aus.
So, was muss man jetzt hier machen?
Also sprich, wir wollen jetzt Debian-Pakete bauen,
beziehungsweise Ubuntu-Pakete wollen wir bauen
für das neueste ZFS.
Voraussetzungen haben wir installiert.
Voraussetzungen für Ubuntu und Debian.
Übrigens, geht euch das neue Twitch-Layout
auch so auf dem Keks?
Better Twitch TV funktioniert einmal richtig.
Alt-T als Shortcut für Theater-Modus funktioniert nicht mehr.
Das dunkle Twitch-Theme ist kacke, finde ich.
Das selbstgebaute von denen.
Ich fand das Better Twitch TV Dark-Theme viel besser.
Und was bei mir auch nicht mehr geht, ist,
dass er während ich quasi die Seite browse,
den aktuellen Stream, den ich offen habe,
dass er den unten beibehält, in so einem kleinen Mini-Fenster.
Ich verstehe den Sinn überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ich verstehe generell nicht, warum, wozu...
Ich sehe keinen Unterschied so richtig
von der alten zur neuen Twitch-Seite.
Es funktioniert bloß die Hälfte nicht mehr.
Da frage ich mich, wozu braucht man denn
die neue Twitch-Seite?
Zumal die jetzt ja auch geforst am Start ist.
Also es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
das Alte noch zu verwenden.
So, für Fudora.
Fudora ist ein Essen-Lieferservice.
Zeug haben wir installiert.
Und jetzt muss man die ZFS-Repos klonen.
Wunderbar.
T-Max und Git muss ich auf jeden Fall
noch installieren, sonst kann ich nicht arbeiten.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Gut, klonen wir mal die ZFS-Repos.
Irgendwie finde ich auch das Terminal-Theme
von Ubuntu grausam.
Wollen wir das hier nicht umschalten?
Keine Ahnung. Naja.
So, jetzt haben wir das...
Warte, habe ich das Repo jetzt schon geklont?
Ne.
So, das SPL-Repo müssen wir klonen
und die sagen, das ZFS-Repo muss man klonen.
Klingt ja auch irgendwie logisch,
dass man das ZFS-Repo klonen muss,
wenn man ZFS kompilieren will.
Hallo Informatiker.
Ist das das neue Ubuntu ohne Unity?
Ja, das ist 17.10.
Ich glaube, 17.10 ist schon, ist genau um 3.
In der VM läuft es halt nicht gut.
Aber ich brauche eine Live-CD, die funktioniert.
Also, wir werden gar, wie gesagt,
wir installieren kein Desktop-System,
obwohl wir hier die Desktop,
den Desktop-Installer haben.
So, was muss man jetzt machen?
CD, SPL und jetzt muss man
Skripte ausführen.
Machen wir.
Führen wir Skripte aus.
Hey, Larin.
Ja, nochmal zum Zusammenfassen
für alle, die jetzt neu dabei sind,
was wir vorhaben.
Wir wollen uns ZFS selbst kompilieren
in der aktuellsten Version,
die im Master drinne ist.
Weil dort die Encryption-Erweitung,
der Encryption-Patch schon mit dabei ist,
dann wollen wir uns einen ZFS,
also quasi ZFS anlegen auf
der einzigen Platte,
die hier in der VM drinne hängt.
Allerdings verschlüsselt.
Und der Knackpunkt davon,
wir wollen davon booten.
Nicht einfach nur verschlüsselt das ZFS verwenden.
Das ist nicht so das Problem.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich relativ easy sein.
Aber wir wollen davon booten.
Und ich glaube, damit ist es echt kompliziert.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig gemacht?
Skripte ausführen.
Und dazu kommt,
dass ich auch nur halb jetzt so im Kopf
mich auf die Sache konzentrieren kann,
weil ich mich mit der anderen Hirnhälfte
quasi auf Stream und Chat
und sonst was konzentrieren muss.
Aber irgendwie wird das schon funktionieren.
Also zumindest ZFS zum Laufen kriegen werden.
Aber ob wir wirklich davon booten können,
da müssen wir mal gucken.
So, wie geht es denn jetzt weiter?
Also ich habe mir die Anleitung
im Vorfeld schon mal ein bisschen angeguckt,
dass ich jetzt nicht total
wie der letzte Kacknoob das mache.
So und jetzt soll man,
also die Vorbereitungen waren jetzt,
ich soll hier irgendwelche Make-Skripte ausführen
und dann soll ich noch mehr Skripte ausführen.
Machen wir alles, wird alles gemacht.
Solange ich mich einfach
nach der Anleitung richten kann.
Ich glaube, das wird funktionieren.
So Packages, das Zeug kompilieren
und Packages dazu bauen.
Das ist ja schon mehr oder weniger fix und fertig
von denen, die ganzen Skripte.
Da muss ich eigentlich,
ich muss die eigentlich nur ausführen.
Ich glaube, das wird funktionieren.
Danach wird es, danach wird es spannend.
Weil wir haben,
wir haben hier eine Festplatte dran.
Das ist die 40 Gigabyte Platte,
die ich an die VM dran gehängt habe.
Ja Informatiker, also Shortcuts hier.
Ich werde diesen Desktop hier nie verwenden.
Ich kenne mich da auch null aus
mit Gnome Shortcuts und sowas.
Was Larine sagt, hast du gelesen,
was Microsoft gemacht hat?
Da haben sich welche die Mühe gemacht,
ein altes Executable zu reverse engineern
und sind dabei bedacht genug Vorgang,
um die Änderung im Code quasi genau
an die Stellen des alten Codes zu droppen
und das in Assembly.
Hä?
Was?
Also sie haben quasi was Neues gebastelt,
was man an der Stelle vom Alten verwenden kann
oder wie?
Wollte ich mir nachher mal angucken.
Wir haben jetzt SPL,
dann bauen wir ein Paket daraus.
Ne, das habe ich nicht gelesen, Larine.
Muss ich mir später mal angucken.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal ZFS kompilieren.
Weil es geht.
Und weil dann der Encryption Patch...
Fuck, ich habe nicht geguckt,
auf welchen Brand ich bin.
Ich müsste auf Master sein,
weil ich das Ding gerade geklont habe.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall auf Master sein.
Wenn ich nicht auf Master bin,
habe ich ein Problem.
Oh, da habe ich was von 0.7.0 gelesen
als Versionsnummer.
Das heißt, ich wäre nicht auf Master,
ich wäre wegen einem Uraltec.
Doch, ich bin auf Master.
Ja, doch, passt.
Hä, haben wir Glück gehabt.
So.
Install Packages.
Das heißt, er hat jetzt Debian Pakete gebaut.
Der hat Debian Pakete gebaut.
Ja, wunderbar.
Paste.
Ja, dann installieren wir.
Mach mal.
So, wie geht es dann weiter?
Next Change to ZFS Directory.
Machen wir.
So, Cramp ist installiert.
Change to ZFS Directory.
Configure.
Das könnt ihr jetzt ein paar
Menüchen kompilieren.
Limbo Chains.
Das sagt, ich habe keine Ahnung,
was du hier machst.
Also, was ich heute probiere,
ist Folgendes.
Ich möchte ZFS aus dem aktuellen Gitmaster
vom ZFS Onlinux Projekt selbst kompilieren.
ZFS ist ein ganz grob umschrieben
Dateisystem mit ziemlich geilen Features.
Und am Ende will ich quasi von einem
verschlüsselten ZFS Dateisystem booten.
Das hört sich jetzt ziemlich simpel an.
Wird es aber nicht sein.
Und jetzt sind wir gerade dabei,
überhaupt erstmal ZFS zu kompilieren.
Da kommt man mal.
So, wie geht es denn weiter?
ZFS Splash.
Next.
Das haben wir ja gerade schon gemacht.
Und dann machst du Millionen.
Ja, mindestens.
Mindestens Millionen.
Aber es gibt lustigerweise,
also wenn wir das hier hinkriegen,
wäre das richtig cool,
weil es gibt,
ich habe keine Anleitung gefunden,
die das irgendwie beschreibt,
wie man von einem verschlüsselten ZFS bootet.
Also von einem verschlüsselten,
mit dem ZFS eingebauten Verschlüsselung bootet.
Habe ich keine Anleitung zu gefunden.
Das heißt, wir wären einer der ersten,
die das hier mal quasi im Stream
irgendwo nachvollziehbar für andere
noch gemacht haben.
So, was habe ich jetzt als letztes ausgesucht?
Configure und jetzt sage ich Configure
und dann sage ich Make.
So, jetzt kompiliert der ZFS.
Das wird wahrscheinlich jetzt
zwei, drei Minuten dauern, denke ich mal.
Übrigens, wer sich jetzt denkt,
krass, wie viel hier im Hintergrund passiert,
bis man das versteht, braucht man Jahre.
Man versteht das auch nach Jahren nicht.
Klar, man könnte sich die einzelnen Sachen angucken
und kommt dann schon dahinter, was da Sache ist.
Aber ganz ehrlich, was weiß ich?
Was? Current biotail exists?
No. Was weiß ich, ob das gut oder schlecht ist?
Was ist biotail?
Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Limbochains, wir schreiben hier Geschichte sozusagen.
So, jetzt machen wir schon mal die Anleitung auf
für Ubuntu 17.10 Root ZMS.
Da haben wir nämlich eine eigene Anleitung für.
Das heißt, wir müssen das jetzt so ein bisschen kombinieren.
Die haben hier halt die Anleitung,
wie man Ubuntu auf einem ZFS installiert,
beziehungsweise halt Root, also quasi von dem Laufwerk,
wo man bootet, ganz billig gesagt,
wie man das darauf installiert.
Die Anleitung funktioniert, das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Aber in dieser Anleitung beschäftigt sich halt null
mit der ZFS-Verschlüsselung.
Die machen das noch mit LUX, also sprich,
mit der in Linux eingebauten Verschlüsselung
für komplette Festplatten.
Das heißt, wir müssen das ein bisschen abwandeln.
Gwin fragt, was sind denn die Vorteile, die ZFS bringt?
Wo fange ich denn jetzt am besten an?
Also normalerweise brauchst du ja unter Linux
ganz viele verschiedenen Tools,
um quasi einen Software-Rate zu machen,
um zu partitionieren, beziehungsweise für Volume-Management,
für Verschlüsselung und sowas in der Richtung.
Das vereint ZFS alles in einem.
Aber es hat noch viel mehr Vorteile.
Du kannst beispielsweise relativ einfach Snapshots machen
von deinen, bei ZFS nennt sich das Datasets.
Du hast jetzt Verschlüsselung eingebaut.
Du kannst relativ einfach quasi sowas,
so eine Art Partitionen anlegen.
Sowas in der Richtung, es sind keine wirklichen Partitionen.
Es sind entweder Z-Volumes oder Datasets.
Also sprich entweder sowas wie Ordner
oder sowas wie eigene Festplatten.
Aber die halt nur so aussehen.
In Wirklichkeit gehören sie zu diesem ZFS-Pool mit dazu.
Es ist schnell, es ist sicher.
Also sprich ZFS verifiziert.
Das, was es geschrieben hat, ob das übereinstimmt.
Also selbst wenn die Festplatte irgendwelche Fehler hat
und irgendwelche Sektoren kaputt gehen,
ZFS merkt das.
ZFS kann das bis zu einem gewissen Maß auch reparieren.
Es ist so eine reine Software-Rate,
was für mich, da kann man sich trefflich darüber streiten,
was für mich ein riesen Vorteil ist
gegen irgendwelche Hardware-Rate-Controller.
Man kann nämlich einfach seine Festplatten nehmen
und an jede x-beliebige andere Linux-Distribution mit ZFS stecken,
Pool importieren und es funktioniert.
Was bei Hardware-Rate nicht so ohne Weiteres der Fall ist.
Da brauche ich erstmal einen neuen Controller,
falls der alte kaputt ist oder einen zweiten Controller
und nach Möglichkeit noch einen halbwegs bau-gleichen Controller,
dass er das versteht, wie die Festplatten zusammenhängen im Raid.
Du hast auch normalerweise keine Probleme damit,
wenn da Strom zwischenzeitlich weg ist,
weil ZFS hat einen Log.
Also quasi ZFS schreibt nicht einfach auf die Platte die Daten,
sondern hat einen Log, was es macht.
Also sprich ZFS hat quasi einen Protokoll, da steht drinne.
Das und das mache ich jetzt.
Und mal angenommen, der Strom fällt aus
und das ist nicht richtig auf der Platte drauf,
dann kann ZFS das anhand von diesem Log erkennen.
Weil es könnte ja, und das wäre mal sein Windows-PC früher,
so zu FAT32-Zeiten und sowas,
mal ab und zu ausgeschaltet hat, ohne das Ding runterzufahren,
er wird festgeschleppt und die Festplatte geht relativ schnell kaputt.
Oh, wir sind fertig, es ist dann fertig kompiliert.
Also sowas beugt das Ganze ein bisschen vor,
was natürlich für Server super ist.
Wie gesagt, es repariert sich in gewisser Maße auch noch selbst
und es ist halt eine Lösung alles in einem.
Man kann da ganz abgedrehte Sachen noch mit machen,
mit quasi für jeden User ein eigenes Dataset und sowas in der Richtung.
Das kann man auch beschränken.
Und richtig coole Funktionen sind Snapshots,
also sprich vom aktuellen Stand Snapshots machen.
Diese Snapshots kosten erst mal relativ wenig zusätzlichen Speicherplatz,
weil die speichern sich halt nur das Diff von Snapshot zu Snapshot.
Und was auch noch gut an ZFS ist für Backups,
ich kann einfach meine ZFS Snapshots,
zum Beispiel Datasets, was auch immer,
kann ich rüber schicken, übers Netzwerk, übers Internet,
sonst wo hin zu einem anderen Server mit ZFS.
Und das ist dann quasi sowas wie ein eingebautes Backup.
So, ZFS kompiliert, jetzt haben wir hier,
was müssen wir jetzt als nächstes machen?
Wir müssen den Kram installieren.
Paste.
Ich ahne, schlimm ist schon, das Problem ist jetzt,
ja jetzt haben wir das erste Problem.
Also ich glaube, dass wir das Problem haben.
Ich muss gleich mal gucken, da muss ich dann was zu erklären,
warum das ein Problem ist.
Ist die Schriftgröße so okay?
Oder soll ich eine andere Schriftart und andere Größe nehmen?
So, jetzt haben wir den Kram installiert.
Und ich glaube, wir haben jetzt ein Problem,
weil in Ubuntu ist ja selbst ein ZFS eingebaut.
Und in Ubuntu ist ZFS Version 0.6.5 eingebaut.
Hallo Captain Sike.
Das Problem ist, Ubuntu hat ja selbst ZFS-Module mitgeliefert.
Und ich habe jetzt zusätzlich quasi meine eigenen ZFS-Pakete installiert.
So, und wenn ich jetzt mal nachgucken würde,
was der Colonel für ein ZFS-Modul laden würde,
könnte ich wetten, er versucht, das in Ubuntu eingebaute ZFS-Modul zu laden.
Was wir ja nicht wollen.
Wir wollen, dass der unser eigenes ZFS-Modul lädt.
Also quasi das, was unter Extras liegt.
Wie ging der Scheiß nochmal?
Ich muss Ubuntu jetzt sagen,
in welcher Reihenfolge ein Colonel-Modul lädt.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das ging.
Da gab es irgendeinen Befehl für eine Config-Datei.
Modeste Sequence-Loading.
Ja, ja.
Näh.
Dep-Mod, Dep-Mod klingt gut.
Das brauchen wir.
Ich muss jetzt sagen, in welcher Reihenfolge er was lädt.
Weil wenn ich ihn jetzt einfach ZFS-Module laden lasse,
lädt er das in Ubuntu eingebaute.
Und das wollen wir ja nicht.
Wir wollen ja unser selbstkompiliertes verwenden.
Wir haben das jetzt kompiliert.
Wir haben die Pakete installiert.
Aber er hat jetzt halt zwei Module zur Auswahl.
Das eingebaute oder halt unser selbstgebautes.
Und er lädt halt standardmäßig das eingebaute.
Hallo Nico.
Hey Max, was hältst du eigentlich von iPhone X?
Holst du dir eines von deinem krassen YouTube-Money?
Also krasses YouTube-Money ist ja bei mir jetzt eh schon eine Weile nicht mehr am Start.
Weil ich schlicht und ergreifend viel zu wenig mache.
Und ich habe ein iPhone 6.
Solange das noch funktioniert, werde ich das behalten.
Wie hat der Kram noch mal funktioniert?
Man konnte dem irgendwo sagen.
Man konnte dem irgendwo sagen, in welcher Reihenfolge er Module lädt.
Etc.
Das ist gut.
Nicht wirklich, aber gucken wir mal da rein.
Ach, ist nicht installiert.
Okay, dann installieren wir noch ein Wim.
Auch gut.
Wisst ihr was, Leute?
Wir machen mal einen Snapshot.
Sicher ist sicher.
Okay, und was sagt mir das jetzt?
Search, Updates, Ubuntu, Build-In.
Ah ja, okay.
Build-In ist was im Kernlein kombiniert ist.
Ubuntu ist was Ubuntu mitliefert.
Was will ich für das Kram funktionieren?
Also wenn ihr Fragen habt, schießt los.
Ich habe immer ein Auge auf den Chat nebenbei.
Wenn ich jetzt einfach stumpf irgendwelche Anleitungen lese, ist das ja auch nicht so
spannend.
Übrigens, Autokorrektur von Google Beste muss man verwenden.
Halo 2, 92.
Ah, ja, Extras.
Das will ich haben.
Wir schreiben das einfach rein.
Easy.
Extras.
Bam.
Ah, Moment.
Es ist Extras.
Jawoll.
Nice.
So, und wenn ich jetzt mal nachgucke, was würde er jetzt für ein ZFS Modul laden?
Hoffe ich mal, dass es 07 irgendwas ist.
Ja.
Jawoll.
Nice.
Jetzt würde er das aktuelle ZFS Modul laden.
Und ich hoffe, ich habe noch kein ZFS geladen.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Wunderbar.
Ja, dann funktioniert doch alles.
ZFS.
List.
Geht nicht, weil keine Module geladen sind.
Dann laden wir mal das Modul.
Please.
Ah, nice.
Okay, das Kompilieren hat schon mal funktioniert.
Alles da.
No Datasets dabei.
Also prinzipiell unser selbstkompiliertes ZFS funktioniert.
Sieht zumindest auf den ersten Blick so aus.
Iron Horse HD.
Wie kompensierst du die Trauer, die Deutschland hinsichtlich der läppischen mobilen Datentarife
verursacht?
Das ist bei mir relativ einfach.
Ich bezahle den einfach nicht selbst.
Ich habe einen 3 Gigabyte Tarif von der Arbeit.
In Anführungsstrichen gesponsort.
Nicht wirklich gesponsort, aber die kriegen ja auch was für.
Ich habe ein Handy und bin da potenziell erreichbar, wenn was ganz Schlimmes wäre.
Aber die Handytarife, die Datentarife in Deutschland sind echt der allerletzte Witz.
Ich habe letztens mal geguckt.
Ich glaube Kongstar war das.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass mir solche Streams unglaublich Bock machen?
Ich kann irgendwas erzählen, was mich interessiert, irgendeinen Scheißlabern zwischendurch.
Links und rechts soll man ein paar Sachen angucken und so muss das sein.
Das ist mir auch vollkommen egal, ob ich da jetzt 1.000 Leute oder 100 Leute zugucken.
So lange wir ein paar zugucken.
Ich habe letztens mal geguckt bei Kongstar und zwar auch, wie hieß der Kram?
Ja, Kongstar bietet kein LTE, das juckt mich nicht.
Brauche ich nicht.
Solange es für Streams reicht.
Hier Daten.
Kongstar hatte doch irgendwie sowas, wo man so einen Slider, wo man selbst konfigurieren konnte oder so.
Ja, sowas hier, wie ich will.
Kongstar zum Tarifieren.
So, da konnte man nämlich sagen, ich telefoniere nicht, ich schicke keine SMS, ich will surfen.
Und ich habe da letztens was gefunden mit 4GB.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe da letztens was gefunden mit 4GB.
Warum gibt es denn das jetzt nicht mehr?
Warum gibt es das nicht mehr?
Ich könnte wetten, ich habe letztens einen 4GB Tarif gefunden.
Und vielleicht gibt es das nicht mehr.
Ja, den Kack hier will ich ja nicht.
Ich will nicht telefonieren, SMS verschicken will ich auch nicht.
Nein, Cyberlink zum Tarif.
Nee, das war nicht das.
Aktion, genau, man konnte Turbo.
So, und das ging aber doch hier auch.
Ich habe mir letztens einen Tarif konfiguriert, da konnte ich den ganzen Scheiß rausschmeißen, den ich nicht wollte.
Weil ich brauche keine Telefonminuten, ich brauche vor allem schon mal gar keine SMS mehr.
Ich finde das jetzt nicht.
Naja, egal.
Das soll jetzt ja nicht um irgendwelche Handy-Tarife gehen.
Aber es ist traurig in Deutschland.
Es ist wirklich traurig in Deutschland, wie das um Datentarife ausschaut.
Und ein Vogel abschießt die Telekom, da ist das Zeug so teuer.
Also die, die sich lohnen, wo man sagen würde, hey, damit kann man arbeiten, damit kann man was machen, die sind so teuer.
Das ist für einen Arsch, ja.
So, weiter geht's.
Wir haben ZFS kompiliert, ZFS funktioniert, ZFS-Module geladen, ZFS-Kommandos funktionieren.
Prinzipiell so weit, so gut.
Dann machen wir mal weiter mit dieser Anleitung hier.
Also sprich, wie installiert man, ich mache noch mal einen Snapshot.
Ich kann nie genug Snapshots machen.
Weil wie gesagt, das ist eine Live-CD, wenn mir das abkackt und die Scheiße, boah, ist halt alles weg.
Ähm, deswegen Snapshots.
So, ähm, dann gucken wir uns doch mal die Anleitung an.
Also das, das habe ich auf meinem Server selbst schon gemacht hier.
Äh, Ubuntu install auf ZFS root, das funktioniert.
Wir müssen das bloß ein bisschen anpassen.
Prepare install environment.
Ah, das haben wir schon gemacht, haben wir auch schon gemacht.
Brauchen wir nicht, PSSH, wir sind direkt drauf.
Become root muss ich auch nicht, habe ich auch schon.
Äh, den Kram muss ich installieren.
Allerdings den hier muss ich nicht installieren.
Weil den habe ich ja selbst.
Wenn ich jetzt hier nämlich suche nach ZFS, dann sieht man auch, dass es install local install ist.
Also sprich, von selbstgebauten Paketen.
So eine wirklich dauerhafte Lösung ist das natürlich nicht.
Also sprich, wenn ich das jetzt wirklich live, also wenn ich das jetzt wirklich auf einem Server betreiben würde,
dann wäre es ein bisschen blöd, dann müsste ich bei jedem kernel-Update quasi neue ZFS-Module kompilieren.
Und wahrscheinlich viel von Hand rumfrickeln.
Aber mir geht es ja erstmal darum, dass man prinzipiell weiß, wie es funktioniert.
Um es live einzusetzen, also wirklich produktiv auf irgendeinem System, würde ich warten, bis es dann ZFS 0.8 gibt.
Also sprich die Version, die Encryption mit eingebaut hat.
Aber wir wollen es ja noch mal ausprobieren.
Ja, ja, be happy, das stimmt, in anderen Ländern gibt es viel bessere Flat Rates.
Sogar in der Schweiz, wo man immer sagt, oh in der Schweiz ist alles so teuer.
In der Schweiz gibt es richtig gute unlimited Mobilfunk-Tarife.
Für, finde ich, Schweizer Verhältnisse wähle ich Geld.
Ansonsten ist das Kram ja da übertrieben teuer.
Okay, wie geht es dann weiter?
Install ZFS, haben wir gemacht.
Und zwar nicht das von Ubuntu.
Disk Formatting.
If you are reusing a disk, clear.
Nein, wir reusing keine disk.
Oh, jetzt wird es interessant.
Partition your disk.
Run disk.
Oh, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Habe ich jetzt auf EFIboot umgestellt, am Anfang meine VM?
Ich hoffe.
Habe ich, oh wisst ihr das noch?
Habe ich umgestellt, habe ich in der VM BIOS oder EFI eingestellt?
Ich glaube, ich habe auf EFI umgestellt, am Anfang, oder?
Ja, ja, gut.
Glück, zum Glück ja.
Jetzt könnt ihr den Scheiß noch mal machen.
Weil ich meine, ich will ja, dass es auch irgendwas mit der Realität zu tun hat.
BIOSboot, naja.
Du machst ja heute Einstimme.
So, partition your disk.
BIOS partitioning, EFIbooting, genau.
So, wir wollen jetzt partition, warum macht er denn Partitionsnummer 3 für Boot?
Beziehungsweise, warum macht er Partitionsnummer 3 für EFI?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich mache das jetzt aber mal genau so, wie das die Anleitung schreibt.
Allerdings nicht Dev, Devdisk sonst war, sondern Devsda, weil halt VM.
Gut.
Wir können uns das auch gleich noch mal grafisch dann angucken, falls es drauf ist.
Und hier, bla, bam, 512, Boot, EFI, partition.
Dann brauchen wir, wie machen sie denn hier weiter?
Ja, hast du extra gesagt.
Ja, ich habe nachgeguckt, habe ich wirklich gemacht, zum Glück.
Also wir brauchen am Ende, brauchen wir drei Partitionen.
Wir brauchen drei Partitionen.
Wir brauchen eine EFI-Partition, die haben wir jetzt hier schon gemacht.
Wir brauchen eine Boot-Partition, ganz wichtig.
Wenn wir das vergessen, bin ich mir sicher, wird es garantiert nicht funktionieren,
weil Krabb kein Encrypted ZFS, also Boot nicht von einem Encrypted ZFS laden kann.
Noch nicht.
Gibt es bestimmt schon einen Patch, gucken wir mal.
Aber in einen Krabb kompilieren wir uns jetzt definitiv nicht.
Nein, Lux wollen wir nicht, auch kein Lux.
Native Encrypted ZFS.
Ja guck, hier gibt es schon einen Feature Request, gibt es noch nicht.
Also Krabb kann das nicht.
Also Krabb kann nicht von Native Encrypted ZFS booten, das geht nicht.
Deswegen brauchen wir auf jeden Fall eine Boot-Partition.
Könnt ihr mir halbwegs folgen?
So, was blöd gefragt, weil ansonsten kann ich noch ein bisschen mehr drumherum erklären.
Also Linux-Boot-Vorgang läuft ja prinzipiell so ab.
Du hast erstmal, oder was heißt Linux-Boot-Vorgang?
Boot-Vorgang allgemein.
Nachdem das BIOS die Sache an den Boot-Manager übergeben hat, in dem Fall Krabb,
und Krabb hat halt eine Konfiguration, wo drinnen steht, was es für Betriebssysteme zur Auswahl hat
und auf welcher Platte die sind und wo die anfangen und sowas in der Richtung.
Und wenn dann das Booten von Linux anfängt, muss Krabb irgendwo ja her an den Linux-Körnel übergeben.
Also Krabb muss irgendwie den Linux-Körnel starten.
Und Krabb kann das normalerweise von allen handelsüblichen File-Systemen machen.
Und der Linux-Körnel liegt gewöhnlich in einem Verzeichnis, das nennt sich slash-boot.
Und von dort versucht eben Krabb, den Linux-Körnel zu laden und an den quasi dann zu übergeben.
So nach dem Motto, Körnel starten, auf geht's.
Ja, in den starten, auf geht's.
Und das kann Krabb aber nur machen, wenn Krabb den Körnel von der Platte lesen kann.
Und Krabb kann den Körnel von der Platte nur lesen, wenn Krabb eben das Satellsystem versteht.
Worauf der Körnel liegt.
ZFS versteht Krabb mittlerweile, aber verschlüsseltes ZFS versteht Krabb nicht.
Das heißt, wenn ich mein slash-boot in einem verschlüsselten ZFS drinne hab, wird Krabb das nicht starten können.
Deswegen brauchen wir unbedingt neben unserer EFI-Partition, dass es überhaupt anfängt zu booten,
brauchen wir unbedingt slash-boot auf einer eigenen Partition, die eben nicht ZFS ist,
beziehungsweise nicht Encrypted ZFS, sondern sagen wir X4 oder so was oder X2 oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
So, so weit zur Erklärung.
Deswegen brauchen wir am Ende drei Partitionen, nämlich eine EFI-Partition,
eine, so denk ich mir das zumindest, eine Boot-Partition mit irgendwas anderem, mit irgendeinem normalen Dateisystem drauf.
Könnte wahrscheinlich sogar FAT32 sein oder so was.
Und eine dritte fette Partition mit dem restlichen Speicherplatz, die dann ZFS verwenden wird.
So.
IchShadowGhost fragt, was ist eigentlich deine Meinung zu Bitcoin anderen Cryptocurrencies?
Ich finde das prinzipiell gut.
Also ich hänge nicht unbedingt jetzt hier an echter Kohle.
Also ich finde Kryptowährung an sich gut, weil es auch ein relativ unabhängiges System ist.
Die Frage ist aber, ob, also wenn die Frage ist, ob es sinnvoll ist, quasi in Kryptowährung zu investieren oder da mitzumachen,
also was ist das halt einfach Spekulation, wie bei vielen anderen Sachen auch.
Ich meine, man spekuliert ja darauf mehrere Sachen.
Man spekuliert darauf, dass die Kryptowährung, auf die man setzt, erfolgreich wird,
beziehungsweise wenn es sich abzeichnet, dass sie erfolgreich wird,
dass der Kurs ungefähr gleich bleibt oder am besten noch steigt.
Man investiert Zeit, Geld, Strom, alles Mögliche da rein.
Also sprich, das ist eine Spekulation, wie wenn ich mir...
Naja, es ist vielleicht nicht ganz so schlimm, wie wenn ich jetzt zu irgendwie CSGO Skins wette oder sowas in der Richtung,
aber sag mal so, ich würde es mal in ähnliche Sachen, Kategorie sagen, wie ich kaufe mir Aktien von irgendeiner Firma,
wo ich nicht genau weiß, wie sich das entwickeln wird.
Also das ist schon Spekulation, da in Kryptowährung zu investieren.
Und es gibt Leute, die sagen, wieso, kostet mich doch nichts, PC mit Grafikkarte habe ich eh.
Die einfachste Antwort ist da drauf, bezahlst du nichts für deinen Strom?
Minen kostet Massenenergie, sprich, Kryptowährung, Mining, lastet den Rechner ordentlich aus,
Grafikkarte, CPU, hauptsächlich Grafikkarte, je nach Kryptowährung.
Und das zieht Strom ohne Ende. Und der Strom ist nicht billig hier.
Also es ist generell fraglich, ob sich Kryptowährung, Mining mit normaler Rechner, also mit so normaler Desktop Hardware überhaupt lohnt.
Wo es sich lohnt, sind jetzt neuere Kryptowährungen, wo es noch recht einfach ist,
neue Einheiten, neue Münzen, wie auch immer es da heißt, in der jeweiligen Währung zu generieren.
Dann spekuliert man aber wieder drauf, dass sich diese Kryptowährung in Zukunft durchsetzen wird.
Also wenn die sich nicht durchsetzt, ich meine es gibt ja hunderttausende Kryptowährungen,
wenn die sich nicht durchsetzt, dann habe ich die Zeit und Geld und Stromkosten auch in den Sand gesetzt.
So, weiter geht's. Also wie gesagt, drei Partitionen brauchen wir.
Wir haben jetzt die erste, die erste EFI-Partition.
Dann machen wir jetzt noch eine, und zwar, warum fangen die in der Anleitung eigentlich von hinten an?
Hat das irgendeinen Sinn, dass quasi, dass quasi EFI-Partitionen und Boot, dass die hinten kommen?
Das ist bestimmt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wir machen das einfach auch so.
So, wir machen noch eine zweite Partition, die fängt jetzt ab 513 Megabyte an.
Warum 513? Naja, weil die andere ja schon, weil die andere bis 512 geht.
Die machen wir mal 2048 groß, das ist einfach so mein Daumen gepeilt, keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich sinnvoll ist.
Das ist jetzt meine Partition, die ich für Slashboot verwenden werde.
So, und nun machen wir abschließend noch...
Jetzt machen wir abschließend noch eine Partition mit dem Rest für, wo dann mal ein ZFS draufkommt.
So, gucken wir uns das mal hier in Gparted an.
Wir haben drei Partitionen, eins, zwei, drei.
Hier kommt später ZFS drauf.
Hier kommt Boot drauf.
Habe ich genug Platz, kann ich einige Körner darauf installieren. Und das ist die EFI-Partition.
Also, von vorne nach hinten.
Gut.
Smokerjumper fragt, Moin Max, habe angefangen Medieninformatik zu studieren
und bin in der Programmierwelt relativ neu. Lerne jetzt mit Java zu programmieren.
Was ist deiner Meinung nach die wichtigsten Sachen, die man wissen muss?
Hast du schon irgendwelche Vorkenntnisse?
Ansonsten würde ich mir einfach mal irgendwie einen Einsteiger-Java-Buch schnappen.
Gibt's ja auch kostenlose.
Und mir das einfach ein bisschen angucken.
Ansonsten ist das Wichtigste, dass man sich auf die Sache einlässt.
Das ist ja eigentlich bei den meisten Sachen das Wichtigste.
Dass man nicht von Anfang an sagt, so eine Kacke.
Ja, und der Nielson hat recht, Google gucken.
Man sollte sich nicht so fein sein, zu sagen, hey, ich kriege das selbst raus.
Oder, ich finde es sogar fast übertrieben, stundenlang irgendwelche Hilfe-Dokumentationen zu lesen.
Weil man kann sich das zwar alles selbst erarbeiten und selbst rausfinden.
Aber oftmals gibst du in Google was ein.
Und die erste Stack-Offer-Floh-Antwort ist genau das, was du haben willst.
Und vor allem von jemand, der weiß, was er macht.
Hoffentlich zumindest.
Okay, weiter im Text jetzt hier. Nicht so viel rumlabern.
So, wir haben die Festplatte partitioniert.
Sprich, ähm, wir haben drei Partitionen.
Lux-Encryption können wir auslassen, das brauchen wir nicht.
Wie geht es da weiter? Create-Root-Pool.
Genau das wollen wir jetzt machen.
So, dass wir das nicht funktionieren, weil es den Pass nicht gibt.
So, und jetzt müssen wir ZFS-Encryption einsetzen.
Captain Seekai Stack Overflow Driven Programming Development.
So, jetzt müssen wir den Pool sagen.
Da habe ich schon nachgeguckt, wie das funktioniert.
Jetzt müssen wir beim Erstellen des Pools sagen.
Bitte Verschlüsselung verwenden.
Und das funktioniert erst ab Version 0.8.
Wenn sie dann mal irgendwann released ist oder halt.
Wenn man den aktuellen, aktuellen, aktuellen, aktuellen.
Masterstand sich selbst kompiliert hatte.
Dann gibt es hier quasi auch die Einträge für, für Encryption.
So, äh, was?
Was gibt es denn hier zur Auswahl?
Für Algorithmen.
IES 128, IES.
Ganz ehrlich, kein Schimmer.
Wir nehmen einfach mal den hier.
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm, geht ja auch nur ums Ausprobieren.
Okay, also.
Wir wollen einen neuen ZFS-Pool erstellen.
Und zwar wollen wir sagen, Encryption gleich das hier.
Wir wollen das Verschlüssel verwenden.
Und wir wollen, äh, Key-Format gleich Passphrase.
Also sprich Passwort.
Wir wollen keine Special Keys auf einem USB-Stick oder irgendwie sowas verwenden.
Nein, wir wollen einfach ein stinknormales Passwort eingeben.
Wenn man onnimmt, ist da Standard IES 256.
Ist da Standard IES 256 TCM.
Okay.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach mal den.
Ist zum Testen ja ziemlich wurscht.
Hallo Imperatorchen.
So.
Die restlichen Settings.
Das ist ja hier so Standard für 4K.
Blöcke.
Mountain.
Müssen wir das nicht direkt.
Compression würde ich immer einschalten.
Also wenn ihr mal vor der Wahl steht.
Sei es jetzt ZFS oder viele andere Datensysteme bieten ja mittlerweile auch sowas für Schlüsselung an.
In der Regel kann man heute Kompression einfach einschalten.
Das ist so optimiert mittlerweile.
Und, äh, ich weiß nicht, ob es CPUs gibt oder sowas die quasi direkt Unterstützung für spezielle Kompressions, Dekompressions-Algorithmen haben, glaube ich nicht.
Aber man kann die Sachen relativ effizient mit den richtigen CPU Instruktionen abbilden.
Und Kompression ist eigentlich sau schnell und kostet kaum Performance.
Deswegen würde ich eigentlich Kompression immer einschalten, wenn es geht.
Blablabla, blablabla.
So, jetzt müssen wir noch die Festplatte angeben.
So, und zwar das wollen wir jetzt erstellen auf SDA 1.
SDA 1 ist ja die Partition, die wir angelegt haben für unser ZFS.
Was hast du bei ZFS schon mal mit De-Duplication gearbeitet?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Hat mich bisher immer abgeschreckt, weil überall wo man was zu De-Duplication mit ZFS liest, liest man, dass das...
Naja, es ist nicht schlecht implementiert, es funktioniert, aber es braucht wohl Unmengen RAM und hat viele Fallstricke.
Ja, ich finde so wirklich wichtig bei De-Duplication ist es hauptsächlich bei Backups.
Ah, Rosenplädchen.
Darf ich mal blöd fragen, was ZFS überhaupt ist?
Darfst du natürlich fragen.
ZFS ist mal ganz grob gesagt ein Dateisystem, allerdings noch viel mehr.
Es ist eigentlich Dateisystem, Volume Manager, Encryption mittlerweile, Softwarerate, alles in einem.
Mit vielen Vorteilen noch dabei.
Also eines der Nachteile von ZFS ist tatsächlich der RAM-Verbrauch.
ZFS braucht ziemlich viel RAM, oder was heißt, braucht ziemlich viel RAM, hätte gerne ziemlich viel RAM.
Okay, zpool create, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, so, das wird schon stimmen.
So, es funktioniert prinzipiell schon mal, es fragt mich nach meinem Passwort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Oh, ist zu kurz.
Na gut.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Bam.
Nice.
Also unser selbst kompiliertes ZFS funktioniert.
Inklusive Encryption.
Das ist schon mal der erste wirklich wichtige Schritt.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert, hätten wir es eigentlich gleich sein lassen können.
Mal gleich mal einen Snapshot.
Was hältst du von...
Hallo?
Warum?
Kann ich das jetzt mal auf Vollbild schalten?
Ich habe keinen Bock, das jetzt im Fenster zu verwenden.
Alter Lan.
Was ist hier los?
Okay.
Äh.
Ich glaube vor allem, wer hat...
Oh, ach der speichert noch meinen Snapshot-Stand.
Vielleicht geht es deswegen nicht.
Ist aber ganz schön lahm hier unten.
Naja.
Ich meine, ich kann immer hier noch Display.
Man könnte, man kann das glaube ich so einstellen.
Was sind das für Drecksauflösungen?
Warum gibt es da nicht einfach 1900?
Gibt es Custom-Auflösungen?
Seht ihr hier irgendwo 1900, 2480?
Machen wir es halt so.
Kann ich auch mitleben.
Vielleicht geht es ja gleich wieder, wenn der Snapshot gespeichert ist.
Oh, es gibt mittlerweile einen Dark Mode.
Das ist ja cool.
Was ist das denn?
Ich glaube einen Dark Mode.
Das ist ja cool.
Warum gibt es eigentlich keine Custom-Auflösungen hier?
Hängen geblieben.
Naja.
Aber das denkt man, so geht das auch.
So.
Was gibt es noch für Fragen?
Was ist ein Dateisystem?
Ähm.
Im Endeffekt ist ein Dateisystem
so die Zwischenschicht zwischen
Festplatte und dem,
was du so in deinem Windows Explorer siehst.
Der Buch halt, da sag ich gleich was dazu.
Also sprich,
ein Dateisystem
ist der Teil dazwischen,
der halt
managt so die
logische Sicht auf die Platte.
Mit dem,
wie es wirklich auf der Platte gespeichert ist.
Also ich mein, wenn du in deinem Windows Explorer
siehst, dass du jetzt hier Video Punkt
MP4 hast, dann
gibt es dieses Video MP4
natürlich nicht so auf deiner Festplatte
drauf. Sondern das
liegt auf irgendwelchen Blöcken verteilt
auf der Festplatte oder auf der SSD.
Und das Dateisystem weiß jetzt
quasi, welche Blöcke
zu dieser logischen Datei
oder zu dieser logischen Einheit gehören.
Und wenn du dann das in deinem Windows Explorer
anklickst das Video und also quasi das dann
sagst, hey ich möchte Video Punkt MP4 öffnen.
Dann sorgt das Dateisystem für,
dass die Daten aus den richtigen Blöcken geladen werden.
So, so ungefähr.
Das glaube ich, umschreibt es eigentlich ganz gut, was ein Dateisystem ist.
Ähm, hast du
vor ZFS produktiv einzusetzen?
Und wenn ja, für was war am
Anfang des Streams nicht da? Ich setze ZFS
produktiv zumindest bei mir daheim ein
auf meinem Server. Der bootet auch von ZFS
aber der Gag
hier im Stream ist jetzt ja,
der Gag
im Stream ist ja, ich möchte eine eigene
ZFS Version kompilieren.
Mit
Encryption. So, jetzt ist der Snapshot
fertig und es geht immer noch nicht ins Vollbild.
Nein, ich will auch nicht installieren. TF
Cancel, Quit.
Geht's, geh weg.
Kann ich das Display wieder...
Kann ich wieder sagen, mach mal
Auflösung automatisch?
Geht das?
Kann man, kann man das abschießen
dieses VMWare Zeugs?
Ah ja, VMWare tut's.
Die killen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Bam! Ah, Quatsch, was mach ich denn hier?
Kill, wo ist denn hier die?
Ok, naja, die VMWare mag
das nicht mehr. Die Auflösung
ändert. Aber da müssen wir jetzt hier mit Clark
mit auskommen.
Ich hätte schon ganz gerne mal
wieder den Bildschirm.
Was? Hallo?
Macht's doch
komplizierter.
Na ja, wir kommen, wir kommen glaube ich
mit der Auflösung auch aus.
So, wollen wir mal weiter.
Wisst ihr was, wir restoren einfach
jetzt mal ein... Ach komm.
Wurscht.
Wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben bei der Anleitung?
Wir haben jetzt unseren
ZFS Pool angelegt.
Apfeltoil fragt warum ich nicht
reinsappen kann, weil ich noch kein Twitch Partner bin.
Und bis jetzt
es auch noch nicht angestrebt hab. So, wir haben jetzt
unser ZFS angelegt.
Hier machen sie irgendwas
mit Encryption, das müssen wir nicht machen.
Ich muss jetzt bloß aufpassen,
dass ich nichts vergesse.
Okay, das
machen wir, das wollen wir haben.
Hier drauf
werden wir dann, bzw. in einem Dataset
hier drin. Ein Dataset ist quasi
in ZFS
man könnte sagen
sowas wie so ein Zwischending
zwischen einer Partition und einem Ordner.
Es ist eher ein Ordner.
Also die voneinander getrennte
Ordner.
Wenn man es so will.
Genau das wollen wir haben.
Darauf installieren wir jetzt gleich
unser Ubuntu drauf.
Ubuntu drauf.
Oh, ich hab ne Donation gekriegt.
Da muss ich nachgucken.
Apfelschorle, 5 Euro, danke.
Da muss man das halt so regeln.
Ja, das ist nett von dir, Dankeschön.
Jetzt haben wir das angelegt.
Wir haben es gemountet.
Äh, haben wir es schon
gemountet?
Wir haben es gemountet.
Wir haben es gemountet, ne?
Wir haben es gemountet, ja, genau.
So, und jetzt machen wir
ne Ubuntu Installation
von Hand. Also quasi
das, was der Installer unter der
Haube macht, müssen wir jetzt von Hand ausführen, weil
wir können den Installer nicht verwenden.
Der Installer, ähm,
unterstützt
kein ZFS und vor allem diese Specialsachen,
die ich hier mache, schonmal ganz und gar nicht.
Ich muss jetzt nur aufpassen, dass ich nichts vergesse.
Ich muss nämlich noch meine
ich muss nämlich noch meine Boot-Panition
formatieren.
Mit irgendwie nem X2 oder 4 oder so.
So, das hier
ist ne schöne Variante. Jetzt
hier sieht man schön die Vorteile von ZFS.
Das ist hier ein ganz gutes Beispiel
für
ähm, was man schönes mit
ZFS machen kann. Also sprich die Teile,
die unterschiedlichen Teile
von so ner Ordnerstruktur unter Linux
werden hier in diesem Beispiel,
das machen wir jetzt nicht, wenn es denn alles in
Hut rein und gut ist, ähm, werden
hier einzelne Datasets angelegt, also quasi
einzelne Ordner, die man unabhängig
voneinander verwalten kann. Das heißt,
und das richtig coole ist, ich könnte jetzt
beispielsweise, bevor ich nen System-Update
mache, wenn ich Angst habe,
dass ich quasi mit nem System-Update oder
mit nem Paket-Update was zerschießen könnte,
würde ich nen Snapshot machen.
Von, äh, von meinem System.
Und der würde dann nur das System
Snapshotten und beispielsweise nicht das
Log verzeichnen, das heißt ich verliere keine Logs.
Und wenn es
nach dem Update das Paket irgendwelche
Probleme macht, dann könnte ich einfach
diesen Snapshot wieder Restoren,
Rebooten gut ist.
Das ist wirklich saumäßig praktisch.
Auch für Backups.
Snapshots an sich sind natürlich kein Backup,
wenn ich den Snapshot dann aber mit
ZFS send, an ein
anderes System, an einem
anderen Standort schicken kann, dann ist es
ein Backup. So.
Jetzt, jetzt, interessant.
Das wollen wir machen.
Wie gesagt, wir verwenden keinen
Logs, aber ich brauche eine extra
Boot-Partition.
Sonst funktioniert es nicht.
Und zwar SDA2
ist meine, wird meine Boot-Partition
sein.
Ja, funktioniert.
Äh, mounten wir mal.
Jawoll. Jetzt müsste ich hier das
schon reingemountet haben. Hier kommt
unser Linux-Kördel rein, klein.
Und es ist wichtig, dass er in einem,
auf einer anderen, das kann ich hier nochmal sagen,
auf einer anderen Partition liegt, dass Krab
den starten kann.
Weil Krab kann das nicht, von einer
verschlüsselten ZFS
Partition.
So, jetzt haben wir das
gemountet. Äh, das brauchen wir nicht.
Das Ordner gibt es nicht. Und das hier
ist die eigentliche, eigentliche
Ubuntu-Installation. Das ist das, was der Installer
unter der Haube ausführt.
Und wir haben, wir haben jetzt quasi
das ZFS-System,
auf dem, von dem gleich unser Ubuntu
laufen soll, haben wir jetzt
gemountet nach slash mnt. Und sagen
dem Installer jetzt, installiere
ein Ubuntu-System, also das ist
der aktuelle Codename für das aktuelle Ubuntu,
was wir hier runtergeladen haben, installiere das System
unterhalb von diesem Fahrt
slash mnt. Das heißt, wenn ich das
jetzt ausführe, müssen wir kurz warten,
bis es fertig ist. Und danach muss ich
gucken, ob ich es richtig gemountet habe.
Also sprich, ob Speicherplatz auf meinem ZFS belegt ist.
Also wir müssen auf den Sack gehen, da ich kein
Vollbild machen kann. Das
ist dezent nervig.
Warum ist denn das so langsam?
Das ist übertrieben langsam.
Oh, ist mal wieder die,
ist mal wieder die Telekom-Anbindung
für'n Arsch.
Das muss normalerweise viel, viel
schneller gehen.
Auch wenn es jetzt da dran scheitern sollte,
wäre natürlich kacke, dass es sich mal wieder nichts runterladen kann.
Hab ich irgendwas vorher vergessen?
Hab ich jetzt nicht. Ich habe ja das System noch gar nicht mal
installiert. Und prinzipiell
funktioniert ja hier
Internetzeugs über die VMs.
Also,
das ist jetzt
das Problem,
dass ich jetzt nicht mehr
mit der VM
wartet mal.
Ich mach jetzt einfach
noch mal hier off und noch mal on.
Sollte eigentlich keinen Unterschied machen.
Die Verbindung zu den Ubuntu
Servern ist einfach, einfach lahm.
So, ich bin wieder da.
Ja, das ist natürlich doof.
Erstens, hab ich gehört, es gibt gleich
Mittagessen. Und zweitens,
die Ubuntu-Server sind am Arsch.
Ah!
Es funktioniert. Okay.
Wir machen dann gleich
nach dem Mittagessen weiter. Ich hab übel Hunger.
Aber das Ubuntu-System
installieren wir jetzt noch. Wir machen
jetzt noch die nächsten paar Schritte soweit fertig.
Also, wir installieren jetzt
ein Ubuntu nach slash-mnt.
Und, ähm...
Es gibt ein leckeres
Nudel. Nudel gibt's.
Wir installieren jetzt
Ubuntu nach slash-mnt.
Gucken, ob das zfs-mäßig alles
funktioniert hat bis hier hin.
Dann machen wir noch mal einen Snapshot.
Nudels, genau.
Haha!
Dude, ls.
Weiß nicht, ob der passt oder weiß.
Eher nicht.
Ich tipp mal eher auf irgendwie Schinken und
Pilze und sowas.
Ja, auf jetzt, komm.
Go, go, send dir den Krempel mal.
Das geht jetzt relativ schnell hier alles.
Weil, ich mein, das ist
eine VM auf einer
SSD, auf einer M2-SSD,
also auf einer relativ schnellen SSD.
Ähm, normale Ubuntu-Installationen,
wenn man das hier mit dem Installer macht,
am besten auch noch auf einer Hardware-Kiste.
Das dauert einen Ticken länger.
Aber hier in der VM geht das recht schnell.
So.
So, habe ich irgendwelche Fragen
über Lesen bisher?
Kann man inzwischen
nicht auch ihre Partner-Subs haben?
Ja, kann man, kann man. Ich könnte mich als
Affiliate anmelden,
aber das sehe ich nicht ein.
Will ich nicht.
Will ich mich als Affiliate anmelden?
Da kriegst du da einen Emote
und Gedöns und ne.
Also, wenn ich
mal das irgendwann mache, dass ich hier quasi
mich auch, dass ich hier einen Sub-Button
habe und mich so
hier drüber supporten kann, dann will ich das auch
direkt als Twitch-Partner machen, da ist dann
auch die Vorteile ab von mehreren Emotes und sowas.
Ich habe richtig coole Emote-Ideen, aber
habe ich jetzt, eigentlich mache ich jetzt die ganze
Stream-Geschichte hier wirklich nur,
dass ich machen kann, was ich will.
Und meine Ruhe habe. So.
Gut, Ubuntu ist installiert unter
Root. Jetzt müssen wir noch so ein paar basic
Konfigurationen vornehmen, die normalerweise
der Installer für uns macht.
Unser System bekommt,
unser neues System bekommt, ach, ich muss erst mal gucken.
Ja.
240 MB kommt ungefähr hin für eine frische
Ubuntu-Installation.
Man sieht es jetzt auch, und das MNT ist quasi
mein zukünftiges
Ledungssystem installiert.
Jetzt muss ich noch einstellen, wie das System
heißen soll. Unser System heißt,
komm. Unser System heißt
Hostname.
So, da müssen wir das System natürlich noch eintragen
in die Host, dass es sich selbst auflösen kann.
Unser System heißt Hostname.
Bester, besser Name überhaupt.
ENS33.
Das ist die Netzwerkkarte.
Wir wollen ja auch, dass es
eine IP hat, wenn es hochkommt.
Bring Swim, Leute.
Visual Mode kopieren, gleich ist
neu formatieren.
Configure
Package Sources, jawoll,
machen wir auch Package Sources.
Zack.
So, und jetzt
kommt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Wir wechseln unser neu installiertes
Ubuntu-System und gucken mal, wie es da so
ausschaut drin.
Das prinzipiell
funktioniert.
Also, wir wechseln jetzt
von der Live-CD in unser installiertes
Ubuntu-System rein.
Haben wir gemacht, sieht gut aus,
funktioniert, läuft alles.
So, erstmal ganz wichtig, den T-Max installieren.
Sonst kriege ich später
Anfälle. Also, die Verbindungen zu
Ubuntu-Servern sind abgrundtief
langsam gerade. Hallo?
Ja, ja, Rocks,
Streams.
Boah, es ist langsam.
Wir müssen den richtigen Ubuntu-Server erwischen,
dann gehts schneller.
Lohnt es sich mit
Wim zu beschäftigen und die Kommande Shortcuts zu lernen
und lernt man das alles so nebenbei? Ja, das lohnt sich.
Es gibt ein paar coole Sachen.
Eine Güte sind die Ubuntu-Server langsam,
ey.
Meine Fresse, ey.
Was ist denn das hier wieder? Telekom-Verbindung, ja.
Komm an.
Das ist mega langsam, ey.
Boah.
Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, sich mit Wim zu beschäftigen.
Wim hat ein paar richtig coole Sachen.
Der Vorteil ist von Wim,
dass man das Ding,
beziehungsweise irgendwie AI, ja.
Oder zumindest in Wim kannst du auf jeder Linie
Distribution installieren. Die meisten Systeme haben zumindest
ein bisschen AI dabei.
Und es gibt ein paar echt coole Sachen.
Ähm.
Was zeige ich dir jetzt am besten?
Zum Beispiel, eine Sache, die viele
Leute immer cool finden in Wim,
ist, also,
wenn das hier jetzt nicht läuft,
muss ich meine
Paketquellen umstellen. Aber ich gehe
jetzt erstmal was futtern. Danach machen wir weiter.
Ähm, so.
Ich zeige jetzt mal eine coole
Sache in Wim. Mal angenommen, du hast
irgendeine Config-Datei.
So, irgendeine Config-Datei hier.
BTC, äh,
was weiß ich, wo gibt's denn Config-Dateien
mal mit Anführungszeichen drinne?
Ja,
Python,
drei, warte, ich, gibt's da irgendwas?
Debian-Config, nee, gibt's nicht.
Ganz schön.
Ich brauch jetzt mal eine Datei, wo ich das zeigen kann.
Sonst muss ich selbst eine machen.
Ist da
irgendwas drinne?
P3-Versions.
Wunderbar. So, ähm,
mal angenommen, ich möchte jetzt
den Inhalt ändern, hier,
den Fahrt möchte
ich ändern hier drinnen.
Die Noob-Variante ist jetzt, wo man sieht,
dass das Wim-Shortcuts wirklich praktisch sein
können. Die Noob-Variante ist jetzt folgendermaßen,
File-Tasten
bis, bis dahin,
äh, Insert-Mode,
löschen und
äh, neuer Fahrt.
So, und Escape. Das ist die Noob-Variante.
Was ein bisschen besser ist,
ist, ähm,
man geht schon mal
mit F-Anführungszeichen an die Stelle.
F ist quasi
F gefolgt von dem Zeichen,
was man sucht, springt zum ersten
Zeichen dieser Art in dieser
Zeile. Ähm,
und dann macht man eben so.
Ist aber auch noch nicht schön,
aber schon besser.
Was richtig cool ist, ich gehe
einfach in die Zeile
und sag C-I
Quote.
Bam. Neuer Fahrt.
Das sind, das sind coole
Wim-Shortcuts zum Beispiel, ja. Also sprich
C-I und dann, was man ändern will.
Change Inner, also C-I,
kann man sich merken für Change
Inner, Change Inner Single Quotes.
Bam, weg. Neuer Fahrt.
Das ist eigentlich die schöne Variante. Und wisst ihr, was das
Beste ist jetzt? Ähm,
wenn ich das jetzt in der Zeile auch machen will,
dann gehe ich einfach in die Zeile und drücke Punkt.
Punkt wiederholt nämlich das letzte Kommando,
was ich in Wim ausgeführt habe.
So, gibt's noch mehr coole Sachen.
Ähm, ich möchte
defaults überall ersetzen.
Sternchen drücken
und schon kann ich mit N
zu jeder, zu jeder Stelle
springen, wo
defaults steht.
Ja, Highlight
funktioniert jetzt an der Stelle, ne? Würde
normalerweise machen, das liegt wahrscheinlich an meiner Config.
Und die könnte ich dann auch wieder sagen.
Könnte ich dann hier sagen, Change
das hier zu dem. Dann sage ich
Endpunkt, Endpunkt, Endpunkt und habe alles geändert.
Also, schon cool, was man da
machen kann. Also Wim
Shortcuts, Lohn, äh,
Lernen lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Guck mal, er hat
im Hintergrund T-Max installiert. Wunderbar.
Ok, Jungs. Ähm, wir machen gleich
weiter. Gibt's da
Bücher oder so, um es zu lernen?
Äh, es gibt, es gibt Wim-Bücher,
ja, aber, äh,
am besten ist einfach, einfach ein bisschen, ein bisschen
ausprobieren.
Kannst dir
kannst Wim, Subreddit
kannst du lesen.
Es gibt ein paar richtig coole Wim-Tutorials.
So, also,
aktueller Stand ist, wir
haben unser Ubuntu installiert.
Wir sind in unser neu installiertes
Ubuntu reingewechselt.
Und es sieht auf den ersten
Blick erstmal ganz gut aus.
Ich geh jetzt Mittag essen und danach
machen wir weiter mit, äh,
Booten von diesem
Ubuntu.
Gucken wir uns gleich dann mal nach dem
Mittagessen an. Ich mach nochmal einen Snapshot.
Snapshot 4.
Jetzt haben wir hier mal Pause.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt
vielleicht nachdem ich, äh, Resume
gemacht hab, funktioniert wieder.
Mit, mit, äh,
Vmware.
Ganz schön sneaky.
Wim hat mich komplett überfordert. Ich brauche
mal ein UI.
Naja, also,
Wim hat hier ein UI.
Äh, das mag nicht.
Naja, gut, ähm,
lässt du deinen Stream an?
Keine Ahnung, soll ich meinen Stream anlassen?
Kann ich machen, dann spar ich jetzt ein Overlay,
mach ich jetzt ASCII-Quarium an
und mach dann
ein Overlay, dass ich Mittagessen bin.
Ups, äh,
gibt's das überhaupt
mittlerweile? Was?
Gibt's kein ASCII-Quarium,
das ist aber, was?
Es gibt, unter Ubuntu gibt's kein ASCII-Quarium.
Das ist fail, Distribution ist jetzt
unten durchgefallen.
Gibt's das nicht unter Ubuntu?
WTF.
Das gibt's nicht.
Ach ne, ha, doch.
Ernsthaft, es gibt kein ASCII-Quarium
mehr unter Ubuntu-Standard-mäßig?
Nee.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich bin echt enttäuscht, Schatz.
Ah, es gibt, jawoll!
Es gibt ein Repo mit ASCII-Quarium,
das ist alles gut, alles gut.
Okay, die Ubuntu-Server sind massiv langsam.
Lass an, okay.
Also, die Verbindung zu den Ubuntu-Server
ist wirklich grausam schlecht gerade.
Okay, ähm, dann mach ich hier
Overlay an.
Zack.
Text.
Mittagessen.
Ups, Mittagessen.
Outline.
Black.
Dass man da was sieht.
Schriftgröße.
So.
Alles klar.
Äh, soll ich die Musik bisschen lauter machen?
Das ist hier, äh, Playlist,
irgendwie sowas.
Chill, Chill-Playlist.
Den Kopf bisschen langsamer
lassen. Oh, ich weiß dann, ob man da Einfluss drauf hat.
Hab ich keinen Einfluss drauf.
Wie schnell der Kopf dreht.
Oh, hier Filter, Filter kann man, kann man GIF,
GIF-Filter.
Render-Delay, ne, geht nicht.
Ich kann sie ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Okay, Leute, ähm,
dann bin ich schon mal kurz was futtern.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
So.
And there is no future, it all becomes one doing, one having.
You will simply become completely absorbed in sound and therefore you will find yourself
living in an eternal now in which there is no past and there is no future, it all becomes one having.
When we make music, we do it to improve your mind, to improve your character
and brings us into a state of peace where we can understand that the point of life is simply here and now.
The journey itself is the point, the playing itself is the point.
You will simply become completely absorbed in sound and therefore you will find yourself living in an eternal now
in which there is no past and there is no future, it all becomes one having.
When we make music, we do it to improve our mind, to improve our character
and therefore you will find yourself living in an eternal now in which there is no past and there is no future.
The journey itself is the point, the playing itself is the point.
The journey itself is the point.
Die machen es einem aber echt kompliziert.
Die großen Fische kommen ein bisschen zu oft.
Ich weiß aber einfach nur Zufall jetzt.